FORCEFULLY DEFENDED HER RECORD.
SUNLEN SERFATY IS LIVE ON
CAPITOL HILL.
TELL US WHAT TO EXPECT TODAY.
>> SENIOR GOOD MORNING, FREE AN
MA.
THERE WERE CERTAINLY CONTENTIOUS
MOMENTS.
JUDGE JACKSON REALLY HAVING TO
DEFEND HER RECORD HOUR BY HOUR
YESTERDAY PUSHING BACK ON
OFTENTIMES FIERCE LINES OF
QUESTIONING FROM HER REPUBLICAN
CRITICS.
>> GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIRMAN.
.
>> THIS SECOND DAY IS KNOWN
AFFECTIONATELY BY A TERM OF
MEDIEVAL JUSTICE KNOWN AS THE
TRIAL BY AR DEAL.
>> Reporter: THE FIRESTORM FROM
THE REPUBLICAN CAMP.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM OF SOUTH
CAROLINA QUESTIONED HER DEFENSE
OF GUANTANAMO BAY DETAINEES.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT'S TRUE,
THAT AMERICA WAS ACTING AS WAR
CRIMINALS IN HOLDING THESE
DETAINEES?
>> SENATOR, THE SUPREME COURT
HELD THAT THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
HAS THE SHORT TO DETAIN PEOPLE
WHO ARE DESIGNATED AS ENEMY
COMBATANTS FOR THE DURATION OF
THE HOSTILITIES.
AND WHAT I WAS DOING IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE HABEAS PETITIONS
IS MAKING ALLEGATIONS TO
PRESERVE ISSUES ON BEHALF OF MY
CLIENTS.
>> Reporter: THE SENTENCING OF
PEOPLE CONVICTED OF CHILD
PORNOGRAPHY WAS ANOTHER
CONTENTIOUS ISSUE ON DISPLAY AS
SOME REPUBLICANS CHARGE SHE IS
SOFT ON CRIME.
.
>> AND DO YOU THINK THAT THESE
LAWS ARE TOO TOUGH, THAT WE'RE
TOO TOUGH ON SEX OFFENDERS?
EXPLAIN WHAT YOU MEANT.
IN THIS CASE IN 2013 AND SEEMS
TO BE THE SAME THING YOU SAID
MANY YEARS AGO.
>> SENATOR, IT'S NOT THE SAME
THING I SAID MANY YEARS AGO.
MANY YEARS AGO, AS A LAW SCHOOL
STUDENT, I WAS EVALUATING A NEW
SET OF LEGISLATION, STATE LAWS
ABOUT REGISTRATION.
AND I WAS ANALYZING THEM, AS LAW
STUDENTS DO.
>> Reporter: JACKSON PUSHED BACK
DENYING SHE WAS LENIENT ON
SENTENCING IN THESE CASES.
>> AS A MOTHER AND A JUDGE WHO
HAS HAD TO DEAL WITH THESE
CASES, I WAS THINKING THAT
NOTHING COULD BE FURTHER FROM
THE TRUTH.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT CASES THAT A JUDGE HAS
TO DEAL WITH.
>> Reporter: OTHER REPUBLICANS,
SUCH AS SENATOR TED CRUZ OF
TEXAS, QUESTIONED JACKSON ON
OTHER CULTURE WAR TOPICS.
>> CRITICAL RACE IS AN IN
TRACTABLE BATTLE BETWEEN THE
RACES.
IT VIEWS EVERY CONFLICT AS A
RACIAL CONFLICT.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S AN ACCURATE
WAY OF VIEWING SOCIETY IN THE
WORLD WE LIVE IN?
>> SENATOR, I DON'T THINK SO.
BUT I'VE NEVER STUDIED CRITICAL
RACE THEORY AND I'VE NEVER USED
IT.
IT DOESN'T COME UP IN THE WORK
THAT I DO AS A JUDGE.
>> Reporter: SENATOR MARCIA
BLACK BURN OF TENNESSEE CLOSED
OUT THE MARATHON DAY OF HEARINGS
WITH A QUESTION FOR JACKSON ON
GENDER IDENTITY.
>> THE WORD "WOMAN" IS SO
UNKHRAOER AND CONTROVERSIAL THAT
YOU CAN'T GIVE ME A DEFINITION?
>> SENATOR, IN MY WORK AS A
JUDGE, WHAT I DO IS I ADDRESS
DISPUTES.
IF THERE IS A DISPUTE ABOUT A
DEFINITION, PEOPLE MAKE
ARGUMENTS AND I LOOK AT THE AND
THE LAW AND I DECIDE.
>> Reporter: AND ANOTHER LINE OF
QUESTIONING FOCUSED ON THE
NOMINEE'S JUDICIAL PHILOSOPHY.
JACKSON TOLD THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HOW SHE
WOULD APPROACH HER JOB IF
CONFIRMED.
>> I HAVE DEVELOPED A
METHODOLOGY THAT I USE IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT I AM RULING
IMPARTIALLY AND AM ADHERING TO
THE LIMITS ON MY JUDICIAL
AUTHORITY.
>> Reporter: AS EXPECTED,
DEMOCRATS GAVE JACKSON PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO NOT ONLY PUSH
BACK ON THE GOP ATTACKS BUT TO
SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ABOUT HER LIFE STORY.
>> YOU ALL WILL CONFIRM ME,
SEEING ME MOVED TO THE SUPREME
COURT, THAT THEY CAN KNOW YOU
DON'T HAVE TO BE PERFECT IN YOUR
CAREER TRAJECTORY.
BUT IF YOU DO YOUR BEST AND YOU
LOVE YOUR CHILDREN, THAT THINGS
WILL TURN OUT OKAY.
>> Reporter: KETANJI BROWN
JACKSON WILL BE BACK ON CAPITOL
HILL TODAY FACING A SECOND ROUND
OF QUESTIONING, THE FINAL ROUND.
AND THAT HEARING IS SET TO KICK
OFF IN A FEW HOURS.
.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE WILL BE WATCHING WITH YOU,
SUNLEN.
THANK YOU FOR THAT REPORT.
JOINING ME IS REPORTER DANIEL
DAYLE.
MANY THANKS TO FACT-CHECK.
YOU WERE VERY BUSY YESTERDAY.
MARTHA BLACKBURN OF TENNESSEE WE
JUST SAW.
THIS IS ON JUDGE JACKSON'S
ATTITUDE ON PEOPLE WHO OPPOSE
ABORTION.
>> YOU MADE YOUR VIEWS ON THE
PRO-LIFE MOVEMENT VERY CLEAR.
IN FACT, YOU ATTACKED PRO-LIFE
WOMEN.
THIS WAS IN A BRIEF YOU WROTE.
YOU DESCRIBED THEM, AND I'M
QUOTING, HOSTILE, NOISY CROWD OF
IN-YOUR-FACE PROTESTERS, END
QUOTE.
WHAT DID YOU FIND HERE?
>> THIS WAS REALLY MISLEADING.
SHE TRIED TO SUGGEST THAT
JACKSON HAD BROADLY DISPARAGED
PRO-LIFE WOMEN AS A HOSTILE,
NOISY CROWD.
BUT JUDGE JACKSON DID NOT DO
THAT.
IN 2001 WHEN SHE WAS A YOUNG
LAWYER IN PRIVATE PRACTICE, SHE
CO-AUTHORED A BRIEF ON THOSE WHO
SUPPORT ABORTION CLINICS.
IT WAS IN FAVOR OF BUFFER ZONES
OUTSIDE CLINICS WHERE PRO-LIFE
ACTIVISTS AREN'T ALLOWED TO GO
UP TO PATIENTS.
AND JACKSON AND COLLEAGUES WROTE
ACTIVISTS WHO GET IN THE FACES
OF WOMEN OUTSIDE THESE CLINICS,
SHOUTING AT THEM, BLOCKING THEIR
WAY ARE A HOSTILE NOISY CROWD.
SHE WAS MOST CERTAINLY NOT
INSULTING PRO-LIFE WOMEN SITTING
AT CHURCHES.
YOU CAN FIND THIS BRIEF YOURSELF
ONLINE IF YOU FIND HOSTILE NOISY
CROWD.
IT DOES NOT SAY WHAT BLACKBURN
SUGGESTS.
>> LINDH SAME GRAHAM OF SOUTH
CAROLINA DESCRIBE THE PRESIDENT
GEORGE W. BUSH SPECIFICALLY AS A
WAR CRIMINAL.
>> I'VE BEEN A LAWYER, TOO, BUT
I DON'T THINK IT'S NECESSARY TO
CALL THE GOVERNMENT A WAR
CRIMINAL IN PURSUING CHARGES
AGAINST A TERRORIST.
I JUST THINK THAT'S TOO FAR.
I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU CHOSE THOSE
WORDS.
THAT'S JUST TOO FAR.
>> YOU REFERRED TO THE SECRETARY
OF DEFENSE AND THE SITTING
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AS WAR CRIMINALS.
WHY WOULD YOU DO SOMETHING LIKE
THAT?
IT SEEMS SO OUT OF CHARACTER?
>> WHAT DID YOU FIND?
>> Reporter: BRIANNA, BOTH
SENATOR GRAHAM AND CORNYN LEFT
OUT IMPORTANT CONTEXT.
SENATOR GRAHAM LEFT THE
IMPRESSION THAT SHE JUST
GENERALLY CALLED THE GOVERNMENT
A WAR CRIMINAL.
NO.
SHE ALLEGED IN 2005 THAT THE
GOVERNMENT COMMITTED WAR KRAO
EUPLS IN ITS INVOLVEMENT IN
TORTURING, TORTURING AND
OTHERWISE MISTREATING FOUR
DETAINEES SHE HAD BEEN ASSIGNED
TO REPRESENT AS A PUBLIC
DEFENDER.
ALL OF WHOM WERE RELEASED.
WHY WOULD YOU MAKE HER OUT TO BE
A LEFTY CAD CAL, DEFENDING
TERRORISTS.
IN FACT, THIS WAS A VERY
SPECIFIC ALLEGATION THAT VERY
SPECIFIC INHUE MAN ACTS VIOLATED
THE GENEVA CONTENTIONS.
SHE NEVER CALLED BUSH AND
RUMSFELD WAR CRIMINALS.
THEY DO NOT APPEAR IN ANY OF THE
JACKSON PETITIONS.
SHE DID ARGUE THAT THE RESPOND
HE WANTS COMMITTED WAR CRIMES.
THEY WERE AMONG THE NAMED
RESPONDENTS.
THEY HAD TO BE NAMED AS
RESPONDENTS UNDER THE RULES FOR
THESE KINDS OF FILINGS.
PEOPLE CAN DEBATE HOW ACCUSATORY
SHE WAS OR WASN'T.
THERE WAS NO SENTENCE THAT SAYS
GEORGE BUSH AND DONALD RUMSFELD
ARE WAR CRIMINALS.
>> IS TORTURE A WAR CRIME, WHICH
I THINK THE LATE JOHN McCAIN
WOULD HAVE AGREED TO THAT.
>> Reporter: CERTAINLY.
>> ON&ON JACKSON'S SENTENCING
RECORD IN CHILD IMPORTANT CASES.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> Reporter: THE UNITED STATES
VERSUS SAVAGE, THE PROSECUTOR
ASKED THAT YOU IMPOSED 37.
THAT WAS A 24% REDUCTION.
YOU IMPOSED 57.
THAT WAS A 41% REDUCTION.
>> OKAY.
TELL US ABOUT THIS ONE.
>> Reporter: NUMBER ONE, THERE
ARE KEY NUMBERS THAT SENATOR
CRUZ DID NOT HAVE ON HIS HANDY
CHART.
HE DID NOT LIST WHAT SENTENCES
THE U.S. PROBATION OFFICE, THE
ARM OF THE COURT, RECOMMENDED
THAT JUDGE JACKSON IMPOSE.
FIGURES RELEASED BY THE WHITE
HOUSE SHOWS HER SENTENCES WERE
REPEATEDLY RIGHT IN LINE WITH
THE OFFICE'S RECOMMENDATIONS AND
SOMETIMES WENT HIGHER THAN THE
OFFICE RECOMMENDED.
SENATOR CRUZ CORRECTLY POINTED
OUT THAT THE PROBATION REPORTS
WERE NOT RELEASED TO SENATORS.
BUT THE WHITE HOUSE DID DISCLOSE
THE FIGURES AND THERE IS NO
REASON TO SUSPECT THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE IS LYING HERE.
NUMBER TWO, AND I THINK THIS IS
CRITICAL, IT IS TOTALLY NORMAL
FOR JUDGES TO IMPOSE SENTENCES
BELOW THE GUIDELINES, LET ALONE
BELOW WHAT PROSECUTORS ASKED
FOR.
THERE IS A PRETTY BROADVIEW THAT
THE SENTENCING GUIDELINES FOR
SO-CALLED NONPRODUCTION CHILD
CASES, WHERE THE OFFENDER DIDN'T
MAKE THE PORNOGRAPHY, ARE TOO
HARSH.
IN 59% OF NONPRODUCTION
SENTENCES ISSUED, THE OFFENDER
WAS GIVEN A SENTENCE BELOW THE
RANGE OF THE GUIDELINES.
MORE THAN A THIRD WERE WITHIN
THE GUIDELINES.
HE IS ENTITLED TO HIS SENTENCING
CRITICISM.
BUT IT SHO